we meet in the middle of the night near
one of Tunisia's border towns these
petrol smugglers have agreed to show us
how easy it is to make the crossing
illegally into Libya the unrest in that
broken state is already spilling over
the border and intelligence officials
fear it could get worse these dusty
tracks have been used to smuggle petrol
cigarettes and drugs for decades they go
between Tunisia and Libya we're now in
no-man's land but increasingly they're
also being exploited by Tunisians who
are heading through Libya to fight for
the Islamic state is of course the same
roots that they use to come back home we
stopped before the border and the
smuggler tells me although the tunisian
military has fortified the area with a
security fence huge parts remain
unguarded the threads from is is
significant last year its militants
attempted to take over the border town
of bend guard a Tunisian czar also is
his biggest provider of foreign fighters
with as many as 7,000 joining it's or
other extremist groups then the message
that is is deploying in in the ground is
a very very appealing one because it's
emotional and it brings money with it
you have youth here that are hopeless
jobless and they don't have any kind of
activity Abu Mohammed trained with
al-qaeda in Libya along with 13 other
Tunisians but has since turned his back
on their radical message speaking to us
on condition of anonymity
he says extremists are waiting for the
right conditions to carry out more
terror attacks my family not means and
they love true
formatting should period as well as I'm
a group ID family autonomous family I'm
sure Freeman really thick the security
forces are scrambling to contain that
jihadist threats in the massacres at the
Bardo Museum in Tunis and the beach in
Seuss 57 mostly European holiday makers
were gunned down just a short distance
across the Mediterranean to newzeas
problems are also a danger to Europe
this is a nice a Marie swearing
allegiance to the Islamic state
he later drove a truck into a crowd at a
Christmas market in Berlin his brother
told me he went to Europe seeking asylum
in 2011 a sock with a purpose area will
be on the record we who acara's Labuan
intolerable one loom erratically
balloonist Sweden a doctor - we
ascertain
Tunisia is the lone success story of an
Arab Spring that has now turned dark
balancing the new freedoms of this young
democracy with an increasingly
authoritarian crackdown on the Islamic
extremists will not be easy
Alex Rossi Sky News Tunisia